bonjour à tous mesdames et messieurs
c'est un plaisir d'être ici avec nous
donc à ce texte limite sa police
négative si je suis là aujourd'hui en
fait c'est parce que j'ai pris une
grosse claque
il y a quelques années lorsque j'ai dû
remettre en question en fait tous mes
cours d'anatomie et de biologie de mon
étape hissène lorsque j'ai compris en
fait que le cerveau était un muscle bien
sûr un muscle c'est l'organe d'où les
cellules se contracte pour faire bouger
le squelette mais je dis ça passe
surtout parce que lorsqu'on est un
muscle n'ai pas travaillé ils s'atrophie
et le cerveau c'est pareil lorsqu'on
utilise pas on a en fait on n'utilise
pas la capacité de notre cerveau
j'ai trouvé en fait cette affirmation là
à travers la pratique sportif donc moi
je suis un passionné de sport depuis mon
plus jeune âge j'ai fait du judo dès
l'âge de 4 ans puis j'ai fait du
football et du rugby
j'ai joué en plusieurs divisions
catégorie en espagne et un jour j'ai
voulu faire un saut qualitative et jouer
devenir joueur professionnel donc je
suis allé en france
et après
deux mois en fait
le 26 novembre 2009 je me suis fracturé
l'épaule je me suis fracturé en fait la
glène articulaires c'est ce petit os qui
se trouve entre la clavicule et
l'humérus en plus de me fissuré
l'omoplate
donc étant donné qu'on pouvait pas me
plâtre et on m'a mis une attelle et je
devais rester immobilisé par des
semaines et des mois comme ça mais à
chaque fois en fait que j'ai somnolé un
peu et que j'essayais de me reposer mon
coup tiré sur mon épaule et j'avais une
douleur atroce
donc pour faire passer le temps ce que
je faisais ces jeux regarder des vidéos
des vidéos de sport sur internet et je
regardais des des sports extrêmes donc
j'ai commencé à regarder du marathon je
regardais le marathon des sables
l'ultra trail du mont blanc et un jour
par le plus grand des hasards je suis
tombé sur le triathlon ironman d'hawaï
et je regardais en fait des triathlètes
qui nageait 3 km de natation qui
et 180 km de vélo et qui courait 42 km à
pied de façon d'affilée et la première
chose que je me suis dit c it seems
symbole c'est impossible
j'aurais j'ai regardé de plus en plus
proche et je me disais mais finalement
il ya des gens qui le font c'est pas si
impossible que ça donc c'était la
deuxième phase
j'ai continué à regarder ses vidéos là
et je me suis dit s'il ya des gens qui
le font pourquoi pas moi et donc c'est
là où j'ai commencé à réaliser le ariane
possible je suis possible j'ai été
surtout ému par une équipe la team meat
et qu'ils profitent donc rude c'est le
nom de famille d'un père et d'un fils le
fils est atteint en fait d'un handicap
est donc le père le remorque en natation
3 km de natation avec son fils derrière
ils pédalent 180 km de vélo avec son
fils assis en fait sur un siège devant
son guidon et le pouce sur 42 kilomètres
dans un fauteuil roulant est ce que j'ai
aperçu c'est que en fait il y avait un
sourire une satisfaction sur le visage
des deux à l'arrivée de chaque triathlon
ironman
ils ont fait 6 triathlon ironman
ensemble et ça m'a poussé à croire en le
iam possible c'est comme ça que je me
suis préparé en fait pendant
une année a entraîné donc tous les jours
ça a été un beaucoup de sacrifices donc
où j'ai perdu 22 kg et après m'être
inscrit en fait un premier semi-marathon
un premier marathon un premier triathlon
distance sprint un premier triathlon
distance courte distance un premier
triathlon distance ironman je suis
arrivé le 26 juin 2011 à ma première
ligne d'arrivée d'un triathlon ironman
et là j'étais en fait piquer par ce
virus ce virus de du sport d'endurance
ce virus en fait qui fait qu'on l'a de
la dopamine on l'a de l'endorphine qui
se libèrent nos synapses de notre
cerveau et comment ça commence à prendre
goût et du plaisir à réaliser ce genre
d'effort je m'inscris sur un 2e
triathlon ironman l'année suivante je
participe à la grogne de francfort le 8
juillet 2012
et là je me dis ah scène tu avais un
rêve d'enfance c'est que celui de
rallier le pays où j'ai grandi où tafer
et édite des études
l'espagne attend pays d'origine à temps
pays où tu es né le maroc et c'est comme
ça que je me suis préparé pendant une
année donc à raison de 8 10 km par jour
d'entraînement en plus d'une séance
d'euphorie renforcement musculaire pour
éviter de me blesser et une préparation
mentale pour préparer la traversée du
détroit de gibraltar
je me retrouve un 25 juillet donc le 25
juillet 2013 donc aux abords de tarifa
donc là à côté de la côte espagnole je
me jette à l'eau il ya un côté de moi
bien sûr une des bateaux être de
l'association espagnole qui homologue la
traversée je suis accompagné par trois
autres nageurs et je commence à nager et
dès les premiers mètres je sens en fait
comme j'aurai une angoisse je sens comme
une main qui m'étranglait c'était
c'était la mère s'était l'océan
c'était la nature c'était en fait la
peur de l'inconnu et là je me suis dit
hassen repenser en fait à tout ce que tu
as fait plus en tout c'est ce mois de
cette année de préparation à chaque fois
que tu t'es jeté à l'eau pour
t'entraîner tu te projeter en train de
traverser le détroit de gibraltar à la
nage donc ce n'est pas en train de
traverser le détroit de gibraltar pour
la première fois tu l'avais déjà
traversé une centaine de fois auparavant
et lorsque je pense à ça et après chaque
mouvement de bras je commence à prendre
plaisir
je commence à retrouver mes repères et
l'âge que vraiment j'essaye de regarder
au fond mais c'était impossible il ya
vait mm de haut
under donc j'essaie de voir en dessous
c'était un bleuet nain et un bleu
éclatant c'était vraiment un bleu
magnifique et je prends plaisir
après treize mille mouvements de bras
j'arrive en fait à tanger j'avais
parcouru 16 km 6 donc j'avais été
déportés de deux kilomètres parce que la
traversée la plus courte et de 14.5 et
voilà j'avais fait 180 minutes
arrivé à ce stade là après avoir réalisé
cette traversée entre l'europe et
l'afrique
mon équipe et moi on s'est dit pourquoi
pas réaliser un projet encore plus beau
qui était celui de réaliser en rallye
les cinq continents la nage une étape
avait été faite il manquait encore
quatre autres étapes et c'est comme ça
qu'est née l'expédition walk and stream
of the world
donc il a fallu en fait est au fait
l'équipe
il y avait ma directrice de projet le
nageur et la coach se sont greffés à
cela donc la chargée des relations
presse et le médecin en plus des
coordinateurs locaux en fait sur les
cinq continents parce qu'on avait besoin
de relais en fait sur place pour la tout
ce qui était logistique et tout ce qui
était donc lorsque jeune âge moi j'ai un
bateau pilote qui me guide parce qu'en
haute mer
j'ai pas de repères donc je fais trois
quatre mouvements de bras et je lève la
tête et je suis le bateau qui est devant
moi
jaso diack à côté de moi qui me
ravitaille il a fallu aussi bien sûr
organisé tout ce qui était vers je mens
tout ce qui était nourriture et
pour cela donc on avait besoin de ces
coordinateurs locaux à savoir
c'était une expédition on n'a rien
parcouru 114 mille kilomètres en avion
donc pour arriver dans ces endroits pour
commencer la nage mais traversée et en
plus de la constitution de l'équipe de
l'organisation logistique il a fallu
bien sûr avoir des autorisations
j'arrive en fait dans des pays en fait à
la nage j'arrive de façon très peu
conventionnel j'arrive pas dans un port
ou dans un aéroport
il faut même des tamponné notre
passeport donc il a fallu avoir en fait
les autorisations et grâce au soutien du
ministère des affaires étrangères de nos
ambassades en fait dans ces pays-là et
de ces pays là en fait ces pays
concernés ici au maroc on a pu avoir ces
autorisations et une expédition comme
celle là aussi avait besoin de
financement et de budget et donc il a
fallu penser à tout cela et on a eu
heureusement des entreprises qui nous
ont soutenus lorsqu'on traverse détroit
de gibraltar à la nage et que l'envoi
devant nous tous ces paramètres que je
viens de vous énumérer
on a l'impression d'avoir une montagne
énorme on a l'impression d'avoir une
vague on a l'impression d'avoir un
tsunami
et pour éviter d'être submergés par tout
ça il faut cogiter il faut réfléchir
pour qu'une expédition réussissent comme
celle là il faut la marque était donc
bien sûr c'est une expédition en fait
qui est noble c'est une expédition qui
est solidaire c'est une expédition pour
lancer un message de protection
d'environnement
c'est une expédition pour lancer un
message de fraternité entre les peuples
mais même comme ça il fallait bien y
réfléchir bien la marque était bien à
vendre pour avoir des entreprises qui
pouvaient nous soutenir et pour avoir
l'appui des gouvernements et des pays
concernés pour cette traversée pour
cette expédition là et vu qu'on met dans
le marketing
ce que j'ai appliqué sur cette
expédition morgan freeman the world est
ce que j'aime est appliquée même durant
mes traversées
c'étaient les objectifs smart en
marketing et donc une objet un objectif
mme un objectif ça doit être un objectif
qu'ils soient simples dans mon cas
c'était rallier les cinq continents à la
neige ça doit être en fait un objectif
qui doit être mesurable
donc c'était le nombre de kilomètres où
le nombre d'heures qu'en fait que je
passais dans l'eau pour rallier en fait
les deux pays à la nage
ou les deux continents il doit être
temporelle nous depuis le début avec mon
équipe on avait décidé de le faire en
donc finalement l'a fait en quatre mois
en juillet août septembre octobre 2014
mais on l'avait déjà l'objectif de fixer
et doit être atteignable et réaliste
donc vu que je vais du principe que tout
est possible que rien est impossible que
iam possible je savais qu'il allait être
atteignable je savais qu'il était
réaliste pour moi mais ce que j'ai dû
faire ce me fixer des micros objectif
pour ne pas mais souffler un chemin donc
lorsque j'étais en train de traverser le
bosphore entre l'asie et l'europe pour
l'étape numéro 2 du projet je
réfléchissais dans cette traversée là
malgré qu au fond de moi je me disais il
faut que tu pense quand même que le mois
suivant tu as une traversée à ou à 6
degrés en fait où l'eau sera à 6 degrés
mais même comme ça il fallait penser de
d'étape en étape c'est quelque chose que
j'appliquais aussi le bon dieu mais
triathlon ironman que lorsque je sortais
de 3 km de natation et que je montais
sur mon vélo et j'avais 180 km de vélo à
parcourir si je me disais il te reste
180 ou après avoir pédalé 20 je me
disais mais ray 120 160 km devant toi
mon corps en fait à les laisser souffler
mon cerveau a les dictats mon corps de
s'arrêter parce qu'ils allaient voir la
ligne d'arrivée un peu trop loin
donc ce que je faisais c'est que je
réfléchissais en tête de ravitaillement
ravitaillement les ravitaillements
étaient situés tous les 16 km donc tout
ce que je faisais en fait c'est je me
disais tous les 16 km tu verrais tu
pédales et 16 km je vais arriver
prochain ravitaillement tu vas arriver
pour chats ravitaillement et c'est comme
ça qu'a arrivé au km 164 je suis arrivé
il me dit restait plus que 16 km et ça
s'est passé ça s'est fait de façon très
fluide et pareil pour la neige est
pourquoi je réfléchis en ravitaillement
c'est parce que lorsque j'arrive au
ravitaillement
je prends des gels de glucose je prends
des lots kim hydrate si une récompense à
mon cerveau mon cerveau est récompensée
et donc il dicte à mon corps de
continuer à avancer pour la prochaine
récompense voilà c'est comme ça en fait
un élève qui prépare une matière ben il
va par ailleurs à étudier la matière
d'un coup ce qui va faire ce qui va
réviser de chapitre en chapitre et la
pause café bar c'était mon
ravitaillement ces thèmes et les gels de
glucose et l'eau que je lui donnais
hamon
et cette fois c'est le contrôle du
mental sur le corps je voulais aussi
bien sûr appris lors de mes traversées
sur les cinq continents
lorsque je dois rallye en fait l'asie à
l'amérique lorsque je dois nager dans
une eau à 6 degrés en plein détroit de
béring je me jette à l'eau et je sens en
plus de l'angoissent comme ce que
j'avais senti lors du détroit de
gibraltar
je sens une claustrophobie pourquoi il
leur faut glisser parce que je sens mes
extrémités en fait se geler je sens une
fraîcheur qui parcourt tout mon corps et
je dois la lutté contre cc c'est ans est
négatif et essayer d'en fait d'enflammer
mon cerveau de faire bouillonner mon
cerveau pour avoir un peu de chaleur et
de les éliminer de n'avoir que des idées
positives
d'autant plus que lorsque je me jette à
l'eau à 6 degrés les pêcheurs locaux de
cette île à 2,7 kilomètres carrés donc
du détroit de béring me disent qu'ils
avaient passé toute la nuit à chasser je
voyais autour de moi du sang de maurs
partout et ils me disent qu'ils avaient
vu un orque qui chassaient des phoques
donc je suis habillé avec une
combinaison noire
je porte donc le gilet gris drapeau du
maroc ou la rouge est prédominant et
j'avais peur que leur confondant fait le
noir de ma combinaison avec la peau d'un
orc et puis le gilet rouge avec le sang
qu'il y avait dans l'eau et là je dois
mettre en pratique toute cette
préparation mentale pour pouvoir nager
malgré cette angoisse pour arriver et
toucher la terre américaine est de
rallier cette étape réalisée cette étape
entre l'asie et l'amérique
j'ai aussi donc il lui refaire en fait
à des petites méduses donc des méduses
irukandji qui ont un revenu équivalent à
celui du cobra entre l'océanie et l'asie
et au bout de trois heures de ménage
après m'être fait piquer par plusieurs
types de méduses je subis par ces
méduses da dont je vous parle de moins
d'un centimètre qui commence en fait à
me paralyser le petit doigt je continue
à nager je ressens je sens plus ma main
ça va crescendo je sens plus mon avant
bras je sois plus mon épaule je sens
plus les l'autre bras aussi les pieds le
ventre je continue à nager ça c'est au
bout de trois heures jeune âge jusqu'à
complété en fait la traversée donc j'ai
nagé 3h46 hélas les garde côtes
indonésien me prenne me mettre sur le
bateau et m'emmène aux urgences pour
éviter que cette paralysie bhl arrive au
au coeur et me donne une attaque
cardiaque donc à travers cette
expédition là j'ai appris qu'il y avait
une certaine marge en fait de manoeuvre
c'est à dire que malgré que ça aurait pu
en fait ça aurait pu être dangereux ça
pourrait être dangereux ça aurait pu mal
finir
j'ai pu contrôler en fait grâce à mon
cerveau mon corps pour qu'il puisse
nager les 46 minutes qui lui est resté
pour pouvoir effectuer cette traversée
là lorsque je j'arrive en afrique
adam en egypte et je dois traverser vers
l'asie
je me jette à l'eau jeune âge pendant
quatre heures et au bout de
donc de ces heures de nage arrive dans
les eaux territoriales saoudienne une
fois arrivés dans les autorités
saoudiennes
après un mouvement de bras je sens
quelque chose se passait en dessous de
moi je regarde en bas je lève ma tête je
regarde ma coach qui à ma droite dans le
zodiaque qui à côté de moi et au moment
où je remets ma tête dans l'eau je sens
une présence à ma gauche je vois une
ombre à ma gauche et là je me dis assène
ne regarde surtout pas l'ombre qui
attaquent gauche donc ce que je fais
c'est que je continue à nager tout en
respirant du côté droit et uniquement du
côté droit
et là je vois que de l'activité de plus
en plus du côté droit
je vois un garde côte saoudien qui met
en fait un shark shield dans sa cheville
donc à charge utile c'est un engin pour
faire fuir les requins et une messagerie
dans l'eau et là je comprends que ce que
j'ai à ma gauche la présence que je
ressens c'est un requin et là je me dis
ne regarde surtout parce que tu as ta
gauche
je regarde en face de moi je vois la
côte saoudienne et moi la côte
saoudienne c'est la ligne d'arrivée non
seulement de la cinquième étape devant
le cam swan the world c'est c'est en
fait la ligne d'arrivée de tout le
projet
si je me paralyse à ce moment là si mon
cerveau est paralysée par cette peur là
mon corps s'arrêtera et toute
l'expédition est finie ça aurait servi à
rien tout ce qu'on a fait donc là j'ai
sorti une astuce que j'avais en fait la
sucent c'était que j'avais demandé
durant ces les jours auparavant deux
j'avais demandé à ma famille à mes
proches à mes amis demandent ils
seraient des messages audio que j'avais
mis en fait dans un mp3 waterproof que
j'aurais pu écouter dans l'eau et que
dans des moments difficiles j'aurais
demandé à ma coach de me donner cette
mp3 et d'écouter ça pendant un court
instant il se trouve en fait que j'avais
tellement écouté en boucle ces messages
audio la veille et l'avant veille que je
les connaissais par coeur
donc j'ai commencé sans lui demander le
mp3 à les réciter un après l'autre
il me restait plus que quatre heures
trente de nage donc j'ai commencé à
mener réciter à méré site et j'ai écouté
ma mère j'ai écouté mon père j'écoutais
mon frère ma famille mes amis et c'est
comme ça qu'il me reste il ne restait
plus que 500 m
pour arriver à la côte saoudienne
lorsque j'ai voulu m'en rendre compte je
vais nager c'est 500 m avec la plus
grande satisfaction donc de 20 jeunes
nageurs marocains qui étaient en train
donc de réaliser cette performance
sportif et pour lancer un message de
protection d'environnement et de
fraternité entre les peuples tout en
levant mon drapeau marocain
j'arrive sur la côte saoudienne je suis
reçu donc que de façon très chaleureuse
par les autorités locales
et là bien sûr j'ai une larme qui ai
essayé de cool qui coule mais j'essaye
de la camoufler comme je peux et c'est
comme ça que j'ai réussi en fait à
rallier l'afrique à l'asie que j'ai
réussi à rallier à railler les cinq
continents et la neige les gens me
demandent le what's next
et quoi faire maintenant la vérité c'est
que j'ai beaucoup d'idées en tête
j'avais en fait
mon cerveau qui est qui bouillonne j'ai
ma tête qui a enflammé mais la question
que je me pose la question que je pense
qu'on devrait tous se poser est la
question que je vous pose
c'est ce que l'endroit où vous êtes
aujourd'hui vous permettra d'atteindre
entre vous voulez aller demain voilà
merci à tous merci merci